AGAIN.
ONTO THE MONOLOGUE ENOUGH OF
YOU.
SO ARE HEARING MORE ABOUT THE
LOCKDOWNS ABOUT EFFECT ON
CHILDREN'S MENTAL STATES.
BUT THAT'S ONLY HALF THE
EQUATION.
SURE THEY MISSED OUT ON TEAM
SPORTS, PLAYGROUNDS, AND FIELD
TRIPS.
ROOFTOP PETTING ZOO WAS A
DISASTER.
ALL THE GOATS JUMPED.
BUT WHAT TO THE KIDS REPLACE US?
I GIVE YOU A HINT IT WASN'T
TWISTER.
IT'S SOMETHING MADE IN CHINA.
NOT CHEAP LAWN FURNITURE COVETED
AND CELL PHONE TALK AND TAKE
TALK.
WAS APTLY NAMED FOR A TIME BOMB
IT WOULD GET FROM TIKTOK?
YOU GET LIKE THIS.
>> TEACHES ON LOVE AND ACCEPT
YOU FOR THIS CHRISTMAS, [BLEEP]
THEM I'M YOUR PARENTS NOW I'M
PROUD OF YOU AND DRINK SOME
WATER I LOVE YOU.
>> Greg: WITH PARENTS LIKE
THAT WHO NEEDS WOODY ALLEN.
THAT PERSON IS SINCE RESIGNED TO
THE FACT THAT HE'S BAT [BLEEP]
CRAZY.
HE'S PROBABLY ARTIE GOT A JOB AT
DISNEY HE'LL BE VP IN CHARGE OF
GROOMING, I MEAN RECRUITMENT.
MAYBE THEY'D DRESS LIKE MICE.
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY NUTCASE ON
TICK-TOCK.
THE APP IS A NONSTOP FAUCET OF
UNSTABLE CREEPS LIKE AN NYC
SUBWAY BUT WITH A DIRECT LINE
INTO YOUR KIDS ROOM.
NEXT STOP IS BRAINWASHED
BOULEVARD, THUS TAKE A LOOK.
>> ME BEING POLY WAS CRAZY.
NOT ONLY THAT THEY ALSO KNOW
THAT I'M GENDER FLUID.
>> WHEN BABIES ARE BORN THE BABY
LOOKS FOR THEM AND MAKE YOU
GUESS WHETHER A BABY AS A BOY OR
A GIRL.
BASED ON WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE.
MOST THE TIME THAT GASES 100%
CORRECT, THERE'S NO ISSUES
WHATSOEVER.
BUT SOMETIMES THE DOCTOR WAS
WRONG.
>> TEACH MY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHERS THAT SOME ARE BOYS,
SOME GIRLS SOME ARE NEITHER.
>> Greg: THAT SHOULD TELL YOU
SOMETHING.
BUT CHECK ADULT PROGRESSIONS
DON'T HAVE FULLY FORMED BRAINS
AND THIS IS WHAT THEY SEE EVERY
DAY.
GOD KNOWS THAT IF I HAVE THAT
KIND OF A BUT WHEN I WAS YOUNG
WHO KNOWS HOW I WOULD'VE ENDED
UP TODAY.
DESTRUCTIVE INFLUENCE IS GONE SO
BAD THAT EVEN PEOPLE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THINGS SEE THAT
IT'S BAD.
IT WOULD KIDS EATING TIDE PODS
INITIATIVE AND IT'S ABOUT.
THE "L.A. TIMES" PUBLISHED A
STORY ABOUT TRANSGENDER WHOSE
HELP HUNDREDS OF TEENS GET TO
TRANSITION FROM ONE TREND OR
ANOTHER.
SHE WONDERS WHETHER THIS SURGEON
TEENS ANNOUNCING THEIR TRANS IS
EGGED ON BY SOCIAL MEDIA.
AT SO-CALLED EXPERTS ARE FAILING
TO EVALUATE THESE KIDS PROPERLY.
I KNOW DOCTORS CAN'T USE THE I'M
NOT A BIOLOGIST EXCUSE.
THEY RECOMMEND HORMONES OR
SURGERY.
THAT MIGHT BE FINE FOR CAITLYN
JENNER BUT NOT FOR KIDS.
IT'S NOT THAT WERE ANTI-TRANS
WERE JUST PRO-AGE
APPROPRIATENESS.
AND TO CONCERN, WHY THE ENTRANCE
AND THE GENDERS OF STRANGERS
KIDS ALL OF A SUDDEN?
NOW ANDERSON IS AT THE FRONT OF
TRANSGENDER CARE IN WHICH HE
SAYS THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
SHE SEE MORE OF A DOUBLING IN
CASES FROM 2019-2021.
SHE NOTES AT THE PATTERNING KIDS
ARE IN QUARANTINE WITH A LOT OF
FREE TIME TO SPEND ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
A STREAM OF TRANSGENDER
INFLUENCERS THAT IF THEY FELT
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THEIR BODIES,
HARDEN FOR IT IN THE STORY OF MY
LIFE.
MAYBE THEY WERE TRANS.
HOW TO CHANGE HER NAME AND
PRONOUNCE IN SCHOOL.
HOW TO PUSH THEIR PARENTS OR
TESTOSTERONE.
SATSUMA TRANS EXPERT WHO IS
TRANS.
SHE CONCLUDES THAT ANY SOCIAL
INFLUENCE INFORMATION OF GENDER
IDENTITY FLATTENS THE FACE OF
REALITY.
SO STEP BACK AND LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENED.
YOU'VE DISNEY AND IT SUPPORT
MOCKING AND SHAMING PARENTS FOR
WANTING WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR
KIDS.
ASKING KIDS TO ASK FOR MORE MOM
BLOCKERS AS PUBERTY.
MAYBE ONE WOULD DELAY ADULTHOOD
TO KEEP INDOCTRINATING THEM.
YET ANYONE WHO DARE MENTION
BIOLOGICAL SEX IN PUBLIC BE
DEEMED TO TRANSPHOBIC.
SOMEHOW MOTHER BECAME OFFENSIVE
WITHOUT BEING FOLLOWED BY THE
EFFORT.
GIVE CRIMINALS CHANGING GENDER
TO GET ITS WOMAN'S PRESENCE
WHICH IS RIDICULOUS, JUST PUT ON
AWAKE AND HIDING ONE OF THE
LAUNDRY CARTS LIKE I DO.
SWEARS ALL THIS COMING FROM?
IT'S SUDDEN.
I GUESS PEOPLE LIKE U.S.
ASSISTANT SECRETARY RACHEL HELP
TRANSITION FROM MALE TO FEMALE
IN HER 50s.
CLEARLY SHE THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT
IT, SO TO CAITLYN JENNER.
WERE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT.
WERE TALKING ABOUT KIDS, AND
WHAT FEELS LIKE A SOCIAL
PHENOMENON AND NOT A BIOLOGICAL
ONE.
THE GENDER VERSION OF TIDE PODS,
YOU KNOW I'M DOING IT WHY AREN'T
YOU?
NO LONGER BE DENIED THIS THE
MORE KIDS WILL FALL INTO THE
SPELL OF INFLUENCERS, THEN THE
KNIVES OF DOCTORS GOT THE
HIPPOCRATIC OATH.
THEY ARE VULNERABLE AND
DESPERATE TO FIT IN AND
DESPERATE TO FEEL SPECIAL.
AT LEAST OUGHT TO BE TOLD NOT TO
PUT THEIR FINGERS IN OUTLETS.
THERE ARE LITERALLY FOR
GROOMING.
AND WHO'S DOING IT?
MAYBE CHECK YOUR KIDS COMPUTER
SEARCH HISTORY, THE CALL IS
COMING FROM INSIDE THE HOUSE.
WHILE MOM AND DAD ARE AT WORK
VULNERABLE KIDS GO ON TICK-TOCK
ATTENTIVE PERSUASION AWAITS.
IT'S MOST FOR DESPERATE KIDS WHO
WANT TO IN SOMEWHERE.
>> Greg: SHE PLAYS SPORTS IN
THE MEN'S WOMEN'S A PASSION AND
THE OTHER THREE HAVE MET AN
UNTIMELY DEMISE.
HOST A FOX NEWS AT NIGHT AND
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK THE
MOTHERS AND DAUGHTERS OF THE
BIBLE SPEAK, SHANNON BREAM.
WHEN HE APPROACHES THE BENCH
JUDGES ASK.
FROM ACCIDENT ATTORNEY
MATT WHITAKER.
HER TAXES ARE LIKE HER HAIR,
LOTS OF EXTENSIONS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND FINALLY HE NEEDS BINOCULARS
TO SEE HIS TOES.
A MASSIVE PSYCHIC AND THE N.W.A.
WORLD TELEVISION WILL CHAMPION
TYRUS.
CONGRATS ON THE NEW BOOK IT GAVE
ME AN IDEA I'M WRITING A
RELIGIOUS BOOK.
SCALAWAGS THE BIBLE.
IT CAN BECOME A RELIGIOUS BOOK.
I'M NOT JOKING.
>> Shannon: YOU COULD DO THAT.
>> Greg: A NOTICE THAT GOD HAS
LIKE 300 ENTRIES, THERE'S NOT A
SINGLE ONE FOR GREG GUTFELD.
I DON'T THINK GOD IS HAPPY ABOUT
THAT.
I'M ONE OF HIS CHILDREN.
YOU HAVE NO CHILDREN AND YET
YOU'RE FORCING YOU TO PONDER
THIS INTERESTING ISSUE KIND OF
THING WHERE EVERYONE IS WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR KIDS NOT BEING
OUTSIDE AND THEY FORGOT TO WORRY
ABOUT WHAT'S INSIDE.
>> Shannon: MY TEACHER WAS
A --
I CAN IMAGINE ANY OF THESE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WERE GOING ON
IN THE CLASSROOM.
NONE OF THIS WAS HAPPENING.
WHAT HE FOUND SO INTERESTING A
COUPLE DAYS AGO THERE WAS THE
OPINION PIECE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" BY SOMEONE
WHO DID TRANSITION FROM MALE TO
FEMALE THE AGE OF 19 MEANT THAT
WRITER WAS SO INTERESTING AS
NOTES INTO THE EXPERIENCE BETTER
THAN THEM BUT SAID THAT I CREDIT
EVERYONE OUT OF MY LIFE WHO HAVE
A QUESTION OR HESITATED OR SAID
LET'S THINK ABOUT THIS.
ONLY 100% APPROVAL AND OF ME
DECISIONS I CAN'T TAKE BACK AT
SUCH A YOUNG AGE.
WHEN I EVENTUALLY TRANSITION
MAYBE WITH A DULL LITTLE BIT
MORE EXPERIENCE.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS HEALTHY FOR
ME TO HAVE ALL THE POWER TO DO
THIS AS A TEENAGER.
>> Greg: KIDS MAKE LOUSY
DECISIONS.
I'M SURE HE MADE A TON OF THEM
GOING UP.
[LAUGHS]
>> Shannon: HR WILL CALL ME.
>> Greg: YES EXACTLY.
ARE THE OLDER YOUNGER?
SO THEY'RE FREE TO MAKE UP THEIR
OWN MINDS.
>> Matt: WHAT I SEE THROUGH
THEIR EYES IS AT SOCIAL MEDIA AS
A MERE AND FEEDS THEM WHAT
THEY'RE INTERESTED IN WHAT THEY
LINGER ON EVEN MORE ON AND
THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY DANGEROUS
BECAUSE OF SOMEONE SPENDS TOO
MUCH TIME LOOKING AT THESE
TRANSITIONING VIDEOS ALL OF A
SUDDEN ARE GETTING A STEADY DIET
OF THOSE TYPES OF THINGS.
AND THAT'S IT'S REALLY INSIDIOUS
ABOUT THE WHOLE SOCIAL MEDIA
WORLD.
>> Greg: IT COULD BE ANYTHING,
FROM ANOREXIA, BAD TASTE IN
MUSIC.
I DO THINK TYRUS, BECAUSE YOU
HAVE KIDS.
[LAUGHS]
YOU A COUPLE THINGS YOU AT THE
ADMIT THAT THE PSYCHOLOGIST HAS
A LOT OF GUTS TO COME OUT AND
SAY THIS BUT SO SOMEBODY
STARTLED PARENTS MAY KIDS JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT HE'S TRANS AND
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO, WHAT
IT MEANS.
>> Tyrus: I TOLD MY MOTHER
MIGHT BE THE INCREDIBLE HULK.
A KIND OF WORKED OUT.
>> Greg: AND A KIND OF WAY IT
WORKED OUT YOU'RE NOT GREEN BUT
YOU ARE GREEN LOOK OF THE
TATTOOS.
>> Tyrus: IT TOOK TIME.
>> Matt: SO HE IS
TRANSITIONING INTO THE HALL.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: YOU BROUGHT IT OUT.
>> Tyrus: I CAME OUT EVERYONE
HAPPY?
I FEEL BETTER KIND OF.
SO WE HAVE RULES IN THIS COUNTRY
IS WHAT KIDS CAN COME HOME FROM
SECOND GRADE IN CRACK A BEER
OPEN.
LIMIT SITE ABOUT THE STUFF
BECAUSE NO ONE DRINK ALCOHOL
BECAUSE HER MINES ARE
DEVELOPING.
SO YOU HAVE TO BE 1818 OF VOTE,
SMOKE, WE HAVE RULES IN PLACE
NOT TO BE MEAN BUT BECAUSE WERE
PROTECTING THE YOUTH SLICK MAKE
BIG DECISIONS.
THAT'S EXTERIOR THINGS.
SO COURTS CAN WHAT YOUR CHILDREN
TO GROW AND MAKE A DECISION WHEN
THEIR MIND IS READY TO MAKE
DECISIONS.
THE PROBLEM IS WE HAVE LEADING
EXPERTS ON NOTHING AT ALL WE
HAVE KNOWN SOCIAL MEDIA IS
PROJECTION.
IT'S MY WORLD, IT'S HOW I SEE
THINGS AND YOU ALL TO SEE THINGS
LIKE ME.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF GENIUSES ON
THERE WITH NOTHING TO BACK IT UP
EXCEPT THEY LIKE TO FEEL
THEMSELVES.
THAT IS A CRITERIA.
YOU CAN MAKE EVERYTHING.
THIS 400 POUNDS, 5-FOOT FITNESS
TRAINERS TELLING YOU THAT IF YOU
DOCTOR ASK YOUR WEIGHT, GO TO.
BECAUSE HE SHOULDN'T ASK YOUR
WEIGHT BECAUSE YOU SHOULD BE
HAPPY BEING AS FAT AS YOU WANT
TO BE.
SO WHY WHEN YOU THEN EMBRACE
WHEN YOU'RE 5-5.
IT DOES MAKE ANY SENSE.
THEY'VE NO BUSINESS PUSHING
THEIR BELIEFS AND THEIR STUFF ON
YOU.
WHEN SONOS OWES IT TO THEM WHEN
SOMEONE SAYS I DON'T AGREE WITH
THE LIFESTYLE IN MY HOUSEHOLD
FOR EXAMPLE I'M A SCIENCE GUY.
BUT MY KIDS MIGHT WANT TO BE IN
THE RELIGION.
I'LL PUT MY STUFF ON THEM.
I LET THEM GROW AND FIGURED OUT
THE SAME THING WITH THEIR
SEXUALITY OR ANY OTHER THING.
THUS THE PROBLEM IS THAT NO
STRONG LINES OF THE SAN LISTEN
TO COMPUTER STUFF WE KEEP IT ON
MY HOUSEHOLD.
>> Greg: I IMAGINE IF
TICK-TOCK WAS AROUND WHEN YOU
WERE A CHILD WHAT WOULD'VE
HAPPENED TO YOU?
IS RIGHT KNOW YOU'RE OKAY.
>> Kat: I WAS REMARKABLY
ANDROGYNOUS CHILD BOTH IN TERMS
OF BEHAVIOR AND APPEARANCE.
>> Greg: WHO DID SHE LOOK
LIKE?
LOOK AT THE SECOND BASEMAN FOR
BAD NEW BEARS.
>> Kat: NOW KIND OF DEPENDS ON
HOW MANY HAIR EXTENSIONS HIM
WEARING.
I DON'T REALLY HAVE A VERY
WOMANLY SHAPE.
BUT HONESTLY BACK THEN --
I TELL MY MOTHER AT ONE POINT
BUT I WANTED A WON'T BE ABLE TO
OUTSIDE EASIER JUST LIKE BEING
OUTSIDE TOTALLY ANDROGYNOUS.
I'M SO GLAD THAT NOBODY GAVE ME
ONE.
THIS TRANSGENDER PSYCHOLOGIST
SANG LIKE, HAM TRANSGENDER I
HOPE YOU TRANSITION MAYBE JUST
WAIT.
MAKE SURE.
THAT'S THEM AND THEY TELL WHEN
THEY'RE GONNA BUY A HOUSE.
I FEEL LIKE GETTING YOUR IS EVEN
MORE KATE LIFE CHANGING THAT.
MAYBE KIDS --
>> Greg: WANT TO GET ON THE
PROPERTY LADDER THEN YOU'LL
UNDERSTAND.
[LAUGHS]
>> Kat: I'M SORRY WE ALL CAN'T
BE AS RICH AS YOU.
>> Greg: THE POINT YOU'RE
MAKING IS THAT WERE NOT
ANTI-TRANS JUST ABOUT AGE
APPROPRIATENESS.
AND THAT'S GETTING LOST IN THIS
DEBATE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN DISNEY GOT
INVOLVED AND IS ABOUT HER
PARENTAL RIGHTS BILL ON THIS IS
YOUR ANTI-GAY, NO, NO.
PARENTS ARE TO SING --
>> Kat: I WOULD BE A DUDE AND
SET UP A WOMAN WITH A VERY DUDE
LIKE BODY.
>> Tyrus: UNLIKE YOU.
AND YOUR CHOICES MAY PRESENT
YOURSELF.
AND HE STANDING UP OR SITTING
DOWN IS IRRELEVANT.
UNLIKE YOU.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE TO SAY.
>> Greg: AND I WANT TO BE ABLE
TO NOT LIKE ANYONE I DON'T LIKE.
>> Tyrus: DO IT ALL THE TIME.
>> Greg: I KNOW.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF HE LIKES
ME.
[LAUGHS]
>> Tyrus: STUFF AND IF THE
LIEN UP.
>> Greg: ON THE GO-